I'm curious what your first reaction was
when Bradley offered you this
opportunity because you do wear a lot of
hats in this production so was there
anything in particular that made you
think I wait can we actually pull this
off here well it was the first day we
met
first of all I've known him through I
saw Jimmy Fallon and he did an air
guitar performance of down by the river
which really blew my mind I thought that
was great
and so when he asked me to come I said
sure because I knew it was a Neil Young
fan and I always say there's two types
of people Neil Young fans and non Neil
Young fans and so I loved him already
for that and so once I heard him singing
at Creedence Clearwater song midnight
special then I heard him nailing it then
I thought okay what this can be done and
I definitely want to be a part of it
because I respect his his craft
what's the biggest difference in just
the regular music producing you do and
producing something for the screen
especially something for the screen
where it's not just about eat
performance it's about a performance
that parallels their journey as
characters yeah I mean we're writing for
characters that that maybe sometimes
aren't necessarily you so that's an
added challenge although there was an
ease to this one because the characters
were very close to home for me and so I
was able to write songs that I would
sing myself and that's that was made it
easier and there's also the interesting
choice of actually performing these live
when you shoot the scenes right how many
times do you go through this is there a
point where you got to you know push
stop could you get burned out yeah I
mean no you know the only problem was
filming was getting up early that's my
problem it's a reason why to have we
would nail it in the studio we got to
track and then we would perform them
live with the track and they would sing
along to it so a lot of so so we so you
know we did I don't know we
we did a bunch of takes but but at least
we've gotten the we we recorded the
music already so we're playing it but
then we you know as we're filming its
immune it's impossibly impossible to do
it any other way I think it's abundantly
clear that Bradley is very naturally
talented when it comes to his musical
abilities but this is taking it to
another level so I kind of want to steal
whatever advice you gave him especially
with the guitar because I've played
saxophone all my life and then I wanted
to play guitar but there's just
something about it that never really
clicked so is there any piece of advice
that you gave him that might help other
aspiring artists out there what I know
is that when you have an ear for music
if you can hear what the right tone is
the right note if you can if you can
recognize the right note then you're the
battles already won and it's just a
matter of training yourself to produce
that note and and you know and that's
just muscle memory in you know your your
voice your throat is an instrument in
itself and you know your hands are
muscles that can be can manipulate an
instrument in order to produce a certain
note so all you have to do is be able to
hear if it sounds good and that's the
battle so for singing do you believe
that if someone can hear the note they
can no matter what actually oh yeah
absolutely not' I can't sing for [ __ ]
but that's because you haven't practiced
in the right way okay yeah okay maybe
maybe we could sit down whenever you're
free okay thank you so much
[Music]